la capitaine nous attendons mon colonel
vous attendez quoi le soldat dos j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être médecin m
j'ai passé l'été à l'école
[Musique]
je peux pas rester ici pendant plaisante
se battre pour moi
tu t'imagines que cette guerre va coller
avec des principes pendant que les
autres vont prendre des vies - qui ont
sauvé ça va être ma façon de servir
voici un petit cadeau des gouvernements
des états unis il a été conçu pour
éradiquer la nuit
désolé sergent je touche pas où ça
ne tuez pas non messieurs vous savez que
ça peut arriver de tuer pendant une
guerre
le soldat dos ne croit pas à la violence
raconter donc pas sur lui pour vous
sauver au combat
[Musique]
pour moi c'est pas une histoire de
religion je crois que c'est de la
lâcheté je suis tombée amoureuse de toi
parce que tu étais différentes et
septembre
est-ce que tu risque la prison comment
je pourrais rester moi même si j'arrête
de faire tousser dans quoi je prends
dans ce monde qui fait tout pour se
détruire
ça me semble pas une si mauvaise idée de
vouloir essayer de recoller un peu les
morceaux soldados vous êtes libre
d'affronter l'enfer du champ de bataille
sans aucune arme pour vous protéger
[Musique]
c'est ramener si toi
il faut que vous veniez voir
qui a fait ça ça c'est le lâche
pouvoir tourner là-bas dumas
il refuse qu'on dirait sans toi
[Musique]
tu as intérêt à y revenir
pitié seigneur fait que je joue au foot
+
de plus
[Musique]